[Music]
movies have always had a knack for
exaggerations and bending the rules of
physics
for the shock and awe that makes us love
them so but there are certain things
that seem to be
so unbelievable to the naked eye that to
those who have a pre-existing knowledge
on how things actually work in the real
world we get kinda bummed
so we have already covered quite a lot
on the aircraft carrier scene of
godzilla
vs counter trailer and now we shall take
a look into the helicopter scene
the one in the recent tv spot one of
those there are many
where there are a bunch of these v22
ospreys and chinook helicopters carrying
the body of kong
well actually kong the body of god will
imply that he's dead when he's still
alive
anyway somewhere in antarctica if i'm
not mistaken
so let's also take a look at how much
gong would really weigh
for this to be possible so let's get
down to it
so kong of 2017 was 104 feet tall and
weighed 153 tons
which is peanuts if compared to the
other titans of the monsterverse
he is essentially an overgrown gorilla
that walks in a bipedal fashion
like us humans although in the teasers
of godzilla vs kong
he is also seen in all fours on all foes
like an actual gorilla
he is muscular and has a very athletic
physique
as of 2021 aside from the increase in
size to around 400 feet tall
a corner looks relatively unchanged
however certain parts of his fur
have transitioned into a darker shade of
brown and other parts to a lighter shade
of brown and even
being black in certain areas as well as
having developed into a somewhat
beard-like structure on his face to
signify his older age
all right with that out of the way let
us get deeper into the lore of gong
he was stated to be just an adolescent
during the events of gong skull island
in 1973
and more than 20 years later during the
events of the birth of gong
he was at least twice his height at
around 200
but the weight is still unknown he was
still growing at that time and now in
godzilla vs com we see him double his
height from 200
to around 400 feet tall so as he grows
taller and muscular
so should his weight also increase he
was 153 tons back in 1973
and given the logarithmic increase of
mars as height grows
he should be anywhere between 50 to 80
000 tons by now
which would allow him a fighting chance
against the big g
so how did those helicopters carry him
on a freaking net
well first of all this is a scene that
was meant to pay homage to the 1962 king
kong vs godzilla movie
whereby a sedated and sleeping kong was
carried over to mount fuji
to fight godzilla he was tied with
gigantic helium balloons
and a pair of helicopters the physics
didn't add up back then
and it sure doesn't add up now as well i
counted the number of ospreys and
chinook helicopters
that were on the scene and it was 16 as
well as 12 more lines of ropes
with unseen aircrafts so let us take the
total number
at 30 helicopters and multi-role v22
ospreys
just to be safe oh we have researched
and found out that a chinook helicopter
a single one
can carry like 11 tons in total and the
v22 ospreys can carry around the same at
more or less 9 tons
or even 10. so all in all an average of
10 tons per aircraft
so with 30 of these helicopters and
ospreys the total lifting capacity of
all of them combined would just be more
or less
300 tons kong's 8am morning brown baby
[ __ ] would weigh
more than that the ape pattern weighs
like we said earlier
between 50 and 80 000 tons and even if
we take the minimum
value and drastically half it we would
still have around 30
000 tons so in order to have enough
lifting capacity
in order to transport kong like what we
saw in the teaser monarch would need
around
3 000 of these aircrafts as you can see
that's not the same number in the teaser
obviously
so anyway what if kong was really built
light
and maybe that would also explain his
agility and jumping off from building to
building
without crushing them down like a fat
kid on a sand castle
so let's say that these aircrafts can
carry more than three times the weight
with new technology in the most of us
kong would be around
1 000 tons then and this might give him
the ability to jump around
and run like a man who forgot his phone
at home however
with one percent of the weight of
godzilla which is a hundred thousand
tons
not a single punch or body slam from
would be able to even move godzilla from
his position
like getting slapped by a small paper
little envelope
or a leaf but anyway there are always
loopholes in the storyline and there are
always critics who would
point them out happily like little
jealous green men watching the big folk
mint out goal
just as long as the scenes are awesome
most of us wouldn't mind at all
after all it's all camera tricks and cgi
wing wing
so that's about it do let us know
whether you are team kong or team
godzilla in the comments section
and so with that we come to the end of
this video hope you liked it and do
subscribe if you haven't
give a thumbs up for support and also
smash that notification bell
for regular updates on all things
monster related right here on mind q
till the next video take care fam